obviously a lot of people as you know
who who listen to this uh are really
invested in growth or risk assets
whether that's tech stocks
cryptocurrencies etc uh there's this
kind of drawdown of price that's
occurring we've seen reports that tiger
global and some of these uh kind of tech
oriented uh funds are down 40 plus
percent uh year to date obviously
bitcoin is down on the year uh what's
your read in the impact to risk assets
or growth type assets as we continue
into this kind of interest rate hiking
type environment
yeah so it's it's interesting right like
so there's there's the macro trade which
is pretty clearly and obviously negative
we're in a negative slowdown from an
economic standpoint inflation continues
to be at a level that is well or much
higher than the fed can tolerate or is
critically allowed to tolerate and so
they're likely to continue tightening
policy but then you have to lay around
the behavioral dynamics right you know
stocks start to go down that by enough
cryptocurrency start to go down by
enough you're gonna start to see uh
consumers businesses other investors
demand liquidity at increasing paces
right and so they're gonna start to look
around and say okay what hasn't gone
down as much that i can liquidate to
raise cash or you know to to get to to
get myself back to flat from a
positioning standpoint right that's an
issue
because you know people always in these
times they sell what they can not what
they should
and so you know let's say if you're um
you know if you're you you you were two
level long uh [ __ ] coins for lack of a
better term you know you might look
around and say hey well bitcoin hasn't
gone down nearly as much so let me go
sell some bitcoin to raise cash right
because i don't want to sell something
down 90 might as well just hold it um
and so to me i think you know i'm not
sure that we're at that point in the
game yet but that's certainly a point in
the game that we see coming just given
our economic outlook and so when you
start to think about how this uh this
plays out if people are selling what
they can not what they should uh is it a
fair statement that you know whether
you're a value investor you got a lot of
liquidity whatever like now is the time
for people to start investing or are
there certain metrics or data points
that you guys are looking at where
you're like yeah we're going to try to
actually wait a little bit more because
we think it'll only get worse
and you know there's not really true
blood in the street like how do you
think about uh either timing markets
identifying bottoms or like when should
the people who don't you know they're
not forced sellers like when should they
actually start to deploy capital or how
do you like evaluate that from a
framework standpoint
great great question i think that's the
million-dollar question and there's a
couple of ways i think um as investors
we we can answer that question my
general framework on when do you deploy
capital in times like these is is sort
of ignore the nonsense about you buy
when there's blood on the streets that's
that's wrong in fact
you're proven to lose money if you buy
when there's blood on the streets it's
called catching a falling life what
typically works is you buy when you hear
the sound of federal reserve andy land
sirens you know to clean up all the
blood on the streets and right now this
federal reserve hasn't even left the
hospital they haven't even gotten in the
truck and so that's my issue with in
terms of you know buying assets at this
particular juncture we i don't believe
at least according to a lot of the
indicators we track whether it be
financial conditions uh whether it be
credit spreads you know which are you
know technically part of financial
conditions it's not it's a belief that
financial conditions have not tightened
enough uh to warrant the federal reserve
you know those those paramedics leaving
the hospital getting in the truck and
going to wherever there is blood on the
streets um you know it's you know if you
look at something like the goldman sachs
financial conditions index which tracks
credit spreads the strength or we
strengthen the dollar uh sort of you
know the equity risk premium real
interest rates uh and i think there's
one more uh indicator in there uh but
that that index you know even as of
today or it'll be updated as a daily get
a little bit worse but prior to this
week
it was this loose and in terms of
financial conditions being loose as it
was at the peak of the dot-com bubble
like we already seen a 15 draw down in
the stock market and financial
conditions were as loose as they were at
the peak of the dot-com bubble so we've
seen nothing yet from financial
conditions tightening standpoint
and this goes back to the comments i've
been making on your show and on other
shows for the last let's go four months
five months which is
man this is a federal reserve that is
comfortable
with pulling the rug out from under us
from an asset market percent perspective
now they're going to get uncomfortable
at some point and that's when you want
to be getting you know getting your cash
ready to buy buy something stand over
fists i mean would love to see 28 000 on
bitcoin i don't think we're going to get
there because that's a lot of smart
people like myself that are waiting on
that level but yeah i mean that's what
you that's when you take out both hands
and back up the truck